25,000 Europeans lose their lives every
year in road traffic accidents saving
lives got a boost as MVPs finally
green-lighted II call the in-car
emergency system which should be fitted
to all new cars in 2018 at a cost of
around 100 years per car works by
sending out a signal to emergency
services when a car is involved in a
collision
it's estimated that it could cut road
fatalities in half but some of the
chamber still raise concerns of a data
protection
okay sure affinity guests Antigua on
Vimeo Sorrento the gang and Viet sanely
fustian talk when he has a comment hurry
that says if you mention laughs in the
1600 padeen on a hint Alice Kailash to
be sharing premier the alarm clock
circuit personal data stored and the Eco
be used in the future this is the
legislation that makes the data
protection safe in this in this regard
because when it's not there the the data
could could fly wherever but it would be
illegal and the data we set in this
regulation will be used only for the
rescue services but one thing still
remains not all Member States recognize
one one to the eu-wide emergency number
equal uses to dial out member states
were to get on their skates as Eco kicks
into action by 2018